most people want to trust that the
person that is telling them about the
world is an honest person
[Music]
like you yes not only are you co-stars
but you're the executive producers as
well
what is something new that you learned
about one another in this process I knew
nothing about your process I didn't know
it everything I mean literally
everything one of the hardest working
women ever same nothing your meaning in
terms of how much you're doing it's it's
incredible when you went right into a
big little lies right into this right
into little fires I mean yeah head
spinning and mark was saying you know
when you guys would cut the guys would
go take a nap in their trailers and yet
we ladies were like working and looking
on to the next scene and working through
the scripts and that sort of thing he
was quite impressed with the work ethic
by you both and I want to know you have
said Jen that this is one of the hardest
jobs you've ever had how instrumental
was Rhys in convincing you to come back
to a major TV show it was it all my it
was all she was so it was literally bow
grease the it was the whole package that
was presented was ideal
you couldn't have dreamed something up
better than this world
[Music]
Michael elenberg Rhys us working as
partners and exploring the world that
I've always loved because I love I love
a good morning talk show yeah and then
learning this the goings on behind the
scenes so yeah it was just right been
rich and exciting Mimi said that people
haven't seen you do such a deep dive
into drama like this before how do you
feel about that I mean it's it was felt
very liberating and quite therapeutic
really how soon because well because
you're you're unpacking a lot of memory
like a lot of memories and things to
evoke an emotion that will truthfully
tell the scene
as best possible yeah so you know you
have to kind of go to some places or at
least I really was and most the time I
just felt like this weight lifted off of
me when we would finish you know as a
scene I mean I've had scene where I
basically vomit on her and it's funny it
can be happy right yeah it can be really
heavy you even name drop our own Mary
Hart your character in the premiere
episode right just remember yes I
remember of course I loved Mary Hart
would you like to say anything to Mary
by gioachino
Mary judge okay what this is a blast
when I was 15 or 14 and I went to New
York City to be part of an acting
competition and Mary Hart was the jest
of it and I got second place thank you
Mary
after playing these roles do you ladies
have a new respect for maybe women like
Mary who thrived for so long like that
day oh yes absolutely I can't even
imagine what people had to endure it and
get through just to have their job just
you know the the silence that was
expected the behavior that was just
tolerated and so it's really fascinating
to be part of this conversation and be
creating characters that look at every
side of the me to experience yes then
we're all trying to figure out how to
act how to behave at work how do we live
in corporate structures and that you
know that are more responsible so I
think there's definitely a perspective
for everyone and then tenor of the show
had to change right from when you were
first developing it how difficult was
that to kind of do a 180 and then jump
right in to the me to movement well it
was it was very important that what the
tone would be and how we incorporated it
into the show and everyone agreed across
the board that it should be is honest
and messy and you know asked the
questions that nobody has the guts to
ask say the things that no one has the
guts to
and as so it sort of just rolled out
very naturally and just go there yes
speaking of Mary Hart anything else
Entertainment Tonight that inspired you
ladies in this series I mean probably
our experience of yes I do have those
cards in your hand card Guttenberg we
had to ask people questions made them
ladies and you've done this yourself but
you know you've already done that with
your network
I was with Oprah not too long ago and I
asked her if she would be on this series
and we saw the picture of you and Oprah
in Alex's dressing room oh yeah is that
a hint
will she be on this end no we'll fund
you're the boss's ladies uh-huh
you can make it I will find out you
didn't make a happen maybe so I mean we
don't mean yes
yeah like lifetime goals yes okay Jen I
know that a friends reboot is like slim
chance like slim to none but what about
a green sister like spin-off or special
with you two and Christina Applegate and
that would be funny that would be funny
what would that look like well we it
won't happen for a long time so
Christina should come on our show
oh she's sure as hell [ __ ] oh I love her
she's so talented and funny yes what
would she play she could play your
sister that's true she could play my
sister yeah she could play another
anchor from right-wing show yeah yes
that's a good idea
just someone to come in and threaten our
both of our positions I love it then you
and I joined forces and really or Oh
talk to Carrie about it yes something
left tick-tock your son showing you how
to use tick-tock
[Music]
three stick we stop we love you on
social media so can you now convince Jen
to join us on the ground oh gosh we need
you Jen I don't think I'm gonna be the
one to have that conversation but I've
been beaten guys people keep talking to
you about it don't though yeah I'm sure
this is not the first time it's come up
no what is your thoughts I'm doing it or
not do you know I just think I listen I
think you could what you resist persists
so I also think you know it's something
that is a part of our world now it does
it's not going away and listening to you
talk about it and how you can actually
kind of have a little bit more control
over the narrative that's out there and
right some wrongs and some silly things
that we'd God knows that are said often
yeah sounds intriguing
yeah so maybe you never may be new to
our friends in real life
what's it difficult on this am i right
you hang right you know we work friends
I know we weren't friends we'd have to
be like yeah we're friends yes I don't
never get to do that of you know what
okay was it hard to be in the tent
scenes with one another or it's just
what you do as actors no it was actually
great because there's this level of
trust I'm like yeah anything you need
from me I'm here for you I can be quiet
I can you know and it's it was yeah a
sense of I got you and hey let me know
if there's anything else I could do
different it's hard to scream at her
though yeah it was a little winter that
one scene was hard it went a night and
it's a nice yeah yeah you're good
screaming ever that feeling no meeting I
hurt my feelings yelling at you yeah it
doesn't bother me never had to apologize
later boy okay so morning show speed
round before a week wrap up how many
times do you hit the snooze button on
your alarm creep okay
yes sometimes yes it's not a yes or no
yes some numbers do it back three so
three is a good one orange juice or
mimosa what day of the week yeah
whatever I want
Monday through Friday is either no I
don't like orange juice I don't either
and s filled with sugar okay
workout or sleep in you're a ghost yeah
a day okay who's the first person you
text or call when you wake up my mom oh
and my daughter cuz she's a college
usually a group of a there's a group
checks that's happening of girls friends
that I usually chime in Jim and last one
where do you catch up on your news in
the morning I listen to podcasts NPR and
New York Times man I look at Twitter
mm-hmm I watched Morning Joe and today I
kind of just surf between good morning
shows love it Congrats lady thank you
son
we love it thank you thank you the part
you guys never seem to realize is that
you don't have the power anymore and
frankly I've let you bozos handle this
long enough we are doing this my way
[Applause]